here's a nice neat diagram right a
hundred times better than what I could
do right you can see I've got my
external point right down here okay
I've got an orange tangent over there a
blue tangent over there and then in
black there's the real guy I'm
interested in
that's the quart of contact right all I
mean in my diagram it's the secant of
contact but you get the idea okay so
that's what I'm interested in okay now
you can see what happens as I move
around as I change where my external
point is right you're just getting your
tangents and moving so your quarter
contact is moving no big deal okay now
what we're saying is the court of
contact this guy and the equation of the
tangent are really the same thing let me
show you how much they're the same thing
if I take my external point X naught Y
naught and I turn it into a point on the
parabola like so pause do you see what's
happening what's happening to those blue
and orange tangents in comparison to the
court of contact they're converging
aren't they watch right there in a sense
of course the court of contact should
give you the equation of the tangent
right because they're really asking the
same question it's just that those two
points right let me bring them back in
those two points where those tangent
that black of your external point
happens to become a point on the
parabola okay so let me just do that one
more time so you can spend it and then
all magically line up okay so don't be
confused when you're like why are there
two formulas sorry one formula for two
things well really teams they're in
thing in different circumstances
depending on where this point that
you're interested in is is it off for it
okay any questions yes it's a good
question now
other thing on here I may try and give
you because I say if you can see in the
top left-hand corner so I can make this
to you if you want you can see how I
have manufactured it you just okay I see
right so there's X naught Y naught which
is anywhere I like and you can see as
I'm use the point now now instead of
watching the point all the stuff on the
right hand side watch what's happening
on the left okay so as I move the point
you can see the values of X naught and y
naught changing right depending on where
I am because just it's just following
wherever I dragged that point on there
okay that was convenient okay I've got x
squared equals 4a Y in there so if I
wanted to change you know the the
concavity of the parabola I would say
well let's make a you know let's make it
a bit fatter there you go that's a fat a
parabola okay and put something over
here or something okay
you can see now let's have a look what's
going on here what's that at the top the
very top that's that's the equation of
the court of contact right that's X
naught X X naught equals 2a y plus y
naught all of this business down here
right I have to get these numbers in
order to work out where these tangents
go right I can't just say work out this
tangent for me I need to give it the
right equations and coordinates and the
way I did that was do you recognize
these orange and blue equations y equals
px minus a P squared I've just got two
different I mean I could call that p and
Q I suppose but I've called P 1 and P 2
and that's why I've got coordinates then
look to a P a P Square and I've just
Federal there now in fact you can see
the colors they match up with that
orange point in that blue point which
give me the tangents ok ah ok so so when
I put this guy inside right do you see
what's happened a couple of things have
broken for me okay
how did I get the point where points
rather where the tangents are
intersecting with the parabola right
well I had to go back and do some of
this stuff but you end up not getting
real solutions so that's why I don't
have any my blue and orange points of
disappeared do you see that that's right
ok because because the values even
though they're not real we'll get to
this next term
you can still do mess with them because
they did plenty of maths just like just
like if you take mm x squared on a B
squared minus C if it right you do its
discriminate it'll be negative okay so
you can't get rid out of this but you
can you get roots it's on a and you can
still work out the product of the roots
it's C on a right they're not real
numbers but you can still do right it
can still do mathematics with where
these equations should go even though it
can't find these points just
geometrically why can't it find points
okay so so algebraically algebraically
yep
algebraically these numbers I if but
geometrically what it's trying to do is
from that black point it's trying to
find tangents let's try to find tangents
there where you cannot that will be
tangent to the problem cuz look I'm
inside the parabola let me come back
every tangent do you see let me make a a
more reasonable value do you see every
tangent right there all outside the
problem they all stay outside the
problem there's no way you can draw a
tangent that goes through the parabola
because then it wouldn't be a tangent
anymore it would be a secant right
so therefore when I go inside you can't
make you can't make tangents in there